russian president vladimir putin shut
down workplaces nationwide this week to
try to curb a devastating surge of the
coronavirus for more than a month day
after day the record death toll has been
rising just this morning nearly 1200
deaths were reported the real loss of
life is likely to be much higher they
say elizabeth palmer has the story
russia is in partial lockdown as record
numbers of people die from covid mostly
the delta variant
the official figures say almost twice as
many per capita as in the u.s
but the real total is far higher says
alexei raksha a former government
statistician and last week
the excess mortality was 3 800 a day
and on average
wow
so almost four times the official
estimate
yeah it's handheld that's what coming in
the great irony is last august the
kremlin announced it had won the race to
approve the world's first vaccine
sputnik v
but it turns out most russians didn't
want it
and ads like this one meant to show that
even tough guys get vaccinated haven't
convinced them
decades of corruption mean they just
don't trust the government
[Music]
in this regional hospital of 750 covet
patients
700 are unvaccinated
overall only a third of russians have
had their shots
and at the outset president putin didn't
help by waiting seven months to get his
now though with a full-blown crisis on
his hands
he's publicly urging everyone to get
immunizations
is this going to be enough
to
get people vaccinated some people trust
putin but most people don't trust
anybody
which means the number of dead
is only going to rise
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer london